taking a step back from this specific
story but um I didn't expect to be the
first one to be selected but I'm more
curious about your writing uh process in
general and you have been so successful
in telling the stories of real people in
a compelling way to the level that they
have been adopted for uh movies what do
you think is in your book and in your
style of storytelling that makes makes
your story so compelling okay and
there's a gentleman behind you there
yeah you were mentioning that it looks
like possibly all of the creditors will
get their money back they may they might
they might um what about the the
Charities the organizations the long-
termist and effective altruist
organizations to whom they had promised
billions of dollars there were projects
that were already gearing up to having
been funded I'm just wondering if you
know what might happen to those cuz some
of them are completely done for yeah so
effective alist organizations that might
have got money that will no longer and
what is it do you think that makes your
writing your books so compelling you
what order you want me to take them any
order you like it's hard to remember
both at once but all right uh so um so
let's the second one because that's a
the the the effect I'll start with that
the effective altruist um uh the the
donations
so there's an interesting intellectual
exercise that needs to be done inside
the bankruptcy that has not been done
and that John Ray the person running it
said would be would be done but it
hasn't been done um told me he would be
done and they that in order to so
there're two problems with the people
who've been given money people who've
actually been given money face the
prospect of having it clawed back by the
bankruptcy that's one kind of problem
and then there people who thought they
were going to get money and the money
doesn't show I don't think it's I don't
don't think that second pot is actually
billions but there are some I've heard
from them and that's just sad and
they're not going to get any money they
it was if it it was promised or it was
hoped for and it's not going to be there
but the the curiouser pile is oh you
already got he gave away I don't know
three or $400 million and did it in a
much of it in a very odd way um they
they looked at the philanthropic model
and said it's kind of busted like that
huge in most philanthropies huge amounts
of money just go to sustaining the
philanthropy to bureaucracy costs and
and to vetting proposals and on subjects
that you don't know that much about so
what they did is they had their buckets
they were interested in they were
interested in mostly existential risk to
humanity but it was pandemic prevention
it was artificial intelligence what
whatever the buckets were they went out
to individuals who they knew understood
who were Specialists and set essentially
you might get an out of the blue this
email from FTX here's a million dollars
give it away in the best way possible
just do it and and you can do it however
you want and we're not going to monitor
it and just tell us what you did so we
can just track to see how effective this
was so there were several hundred people
who got that email and gave that money
away but but means that the gifts were
in pretty small amounts and I don't
think worth the while of the bankruptcy
to try to go get so I don't think
they're going to claw back but the
intellectual exercise they have to
engage in to claw back is to prove that
the money was given away FTX was
actually bankrupt and the the question
is when was FTX bankrupt it it it
certainly wasn't bankrupt in February of
last year it was it there was there was
Triple or double the number of customer
deposits there there was so there's some
moment either when crypto collapses or
maybe it's not even till November of
last year when you could actually prove
that it was bankrupt and if they can't
prove it was bankrupt they can't claw
back so I I don't the only only people
whove given back money are people who
are embarrassed by it the money the
politicians kind of they've been a bit
of that but they don't have to give the
money back and I would love to see
someone fight it because I think you're
going to probably get
to the argument is going to be it's
going to be somewhere it's going to be
pretty late in the day in FTX is life
before it's actually bankrupt uh writing
process like why do you want me to ask
explain why they get made into movies or
just why I like my books sell uh the
both kind of so the process
is I have asked myself this because I'm
a curious creature as a writer I don't
most writers had a sense of themselves
as writers pretty young and I had no
sense of myself as a writer until I got
out of college and nobody ever said I
swear to you no one ever saw promise in
me no one no English teacher said oh you
really have talent you really should I
had no Walter Mish like fantasy nothing
so never wrote for a school newspaper so
it's strange that my life has taken the
course it's
taken what happened in my case was I
became when I was a senior in college
wholly absorbed with a book length
thesis I had to write and it turned out
very very well intellectually not very
well literarily so poorly literarily
that when I asked my professor what do
you think of the writing he said put it
this way never try to make a living at
it but I I I did I did try to make a
living at it and and I did it because it
was the one thing I'd ever done that
could be construed as work that during
which I lost track of time and it was
here in London I would living up in
Hamstead and our St John's Wood first
but then Hamstead and then I would I
would I don't know why I had to need to
make that distinction but the but but
but they all quite different yeah I know
they're different but but I can remember
hours would pass I'd write some article
that would be rejected by some place and
hours would pass and I wouldn't know it
had passed I also noticed that when I
wrote letters to people in a more in a
real self-conscious way like here's
what's going on in London now they would
get passed around like you know I would
come home go home to New Orleans and
people would come up and say I read that
letter you wrote your mother it's all
over the place it's funny and I thought
well people want people want to read me
they they they will they will read me um
so I had and I think it I think to the
extent there was any ability it was some
kind of voice on the page that I can't
explain and that would never have been
identified by um Academia at any school
at any point because they don't ask for
voice they ask for you know a thesis
statement and a blah blah blah and you
never yourself in school but when I was
myself on the page it somehow worked and
I don't want to know why it just like
works and I don't want to stop um but
for the subjects like why the things
work this this is this is going to sound
like but I think it's true I'm
basically an incredibly lazy person like
left I'm in you know an object at rest
will remain at rest I will remain at
rest longer than any other object that I
just don't I don't have an Impulse to
work so for something to get my
attention to the point where I'll get
off my ass and actually do something
about it it's got to be really exciting
I get really you can tell I get really
worked up about the subjects so I'm it's
passing through a filter to get to the
point where I'm going to write about it
I'm not going to just write a book to
write a book right now I may never write
another book again like I don't care if
I I would like to but I I don't care
that much I'm prepared that that's I've
never found a subject that will excite
me again and I won't do it ever again
the fact that like I it has to Rouse me
I think gets me to a place with the
reader where it Rouses the reader too I
also think that as for not as it's it's
a this genre I work in is particularly
americ American genre it's heavily
heavily reported like people think I
just have an opinion about Sam bman
freed I don't have an opinion or or my
opinion is earned anyway it's a year and
a half of hundreds of hours of immersion
not just with him but everything around
him and I don't I wouldn't if you'd
asked me after six months write a book I
couldn't have done it I this is a funny
thing the day before FTX collapsed I was
with a very famous film director who who
has become a kind of friend who I use as
a sounding board for story because I
admire his story his story instincts and
I said to him I got this problem I've
spent a year and two months marinating
in this world and I described Sam the
character I described a bunch of scenes
I said I've got all this stuff but I
don't have a story and I can't figure
out why I don't have a story and he said
you don't have a story because you don't
have a third act there's no ending to
this and I said that's exactly that's EX
exactly right and it's also right that I
don't know how to start it unless I Know
How It Ends like I've had books where I
know the last sentence I knew the last
like the last words of this book before
I wrote the first words of the book
sometimes it changes but sometimes I
actually am navigating to a point I know
and I know where to navigate to so I was
prepared at that moment not to write the
book and uh it wasn't until I was
absolutely like had it in the bag and
was sure that I even bother to sit down
and write the book and I think that
helps I think that like the walkway
ability like don't do it unless it
actually feels right as a story really
helps with the with the readers and
probably with the movies too because it
gives them some
structure